welcome everyone this is Rob Sanders
with simply learned and today we're
gonna talk about Google Analytics I'm
very excited to be with you today
because Google Analytics is one of my
favorite Google platforms and my
favorite topics so let's talk about what
we're gonna cover today I'm gonna start
out with how to set up a Google
Analytics account and so we're gonna
talk about everything that entails
including creating your Google Analytics
account we're gonna talk about setting
up a property in your account and what a
property is we're gonna talk about
setting up a reporting view and your
property and we're gonna talk about
installing the tracking code so those
are the series of steps we're gonna go
through today in terms of setting up a
Google Analytics account so let's get
right to it and so really the brewing
prerequisite here when it comes to
setting up a Google Analytics account is
to have a Google login and ID so when
you actually go to Google Analytics you
need to be able to sign up or sign in
and so once you actually sign in now
you're gonna go walk through a series of
steps but really that's really all you
need to get the account going is a
Google ID and login so if you have a
gmail account or an other email account
that you use for other Google products
then you're good to go that's all you
need to do so when you actually go to
sign up for Google Analytics you're
gonna be asked to set up a new account
and these are the series of steps you're
gonna walk through or go through to set
up a new Google Analytics account so
you're gonna choose an account name and
then you're gonna choose a property name
okay so the account name can be anything
you want it to be the name your company
your name whatever you want to name it
the property name
is really the website name so what
website are we talking about so here I'm
going to set up a fictitious website
name for now it's called demo simply
learn so the URL for this website demo
simply learned is going to be demo dot
simply learn comm so that's the property
when we talk about properties in
analytics we're really talking about
what websites we want to measure and
then you're going to be asked to choose
an industry category and so for simply
learn where in jobs and education but
you have a number of different
industries that you could choose from
it's as important go ahead and choose
the most relevant industry that your
particular business is associated with
ok and I'm going to talk about why
that's important here in a minute and
then you're going to choose your time
zone and the time zone is also important
because that's when the day starts in
analytics then the day ends based on
that time zone so the data that Google
Analytics collects starts and ends with
that time zone so very important to
choose the time zone your business is
located in ok and then you have some
additional options here ok so you have
some settings and so the first setting
is to allow Google products and services
so if you opt into this then basically
what Google's going to do is share some
products and services with you via email
I would go ahead and opt-in to that
that's of course recommended by Google
it doesn't hurt to hear from Google on
related products and services that may
enhance your business
the second is benchmarking so
benchmarking to me is something you
should opt into so going back to the
industry and category we chose jobs and
education so by opting into benchmarking
basically what Google's going to do is
share your data that it collects on your
website in this case demo dot simpler
com it's going to share that data
anonymously with others in the industry
in this case jobs in education and
because you've opted in it's going to do
the same exact
for you it's going to share anonymous
data on other websites in the same
industry and the benefit of that is we
get to see what other websites or how
other websites are performing compared
to ours what's the benchmark in our
industry and so the benchmarking to me
is important I'm gonna go over that in a
few minutes when we go over the
different reports but to me I would
always opt into benchmarking because
this is the only report Google provides
in analytics about how others in your
industry's performing versus your
website okay so it's a way to compare
your website performance against others
in the same industry the other options
here technical support and account
specialists I would also recommend you
opt into those because then it allows
you to basically Google allow Google
access to your account and they'll be
able to help you if you occur or run
into any issues so these are the options
and setting up a Google Analytics
account it's very simple very easy to do
you're just entering in a few fields
note that we talking about a website
right now so I'm talking about demo dot
simply learn com but just know that if
you want to track a mobile app Google
Analytics will allow you to do that as
well you just choose the option mobile
app so we're tracking a website we want
to know how users behave when they get
to my website and that's what Google
Analytics is going to allow us to
measure and look at we just need to do a
couple more steps in the process so once
we fill out these fields here we're
gonna click get tracking ID now I'm
going to accept the Terms of Service I'm
going to accept another Terms of Service
in relation to data protection I'm going
to click accept
once I accept I'm gonna be able to get
some tracking code the tracking ID is
the ID associated
with your account and so this number is
going to be associated with your account
so your account ID starts with UA and
it's gonna be this number here now the -
one is the property you set up so in
this case I set up demo dot simply learn
comm if I want to detract multiple
websites under that same account then I
can certainly set up multiple properties
just know that every property I set up
in that account is going to have a - one
- two - three - four etc depending on
how many properties I set up so by
default I set up one property so my
first property ID is - one if I set up a
second property the same account number
it's just gonna have a - two and that's
important because that ID that account
and property ID is going to be
associated with that particular property
or website so again once you finish
setting up the account settings then
you're going to be asked to add some
tracking code to your site and that
tracking code is going to be related to
the account and the property so notice
my tracking ID up here notice the
tracking ID in the snippet of code now
this snippet of code needs to go on
every page of your website that you want
to track and you don't have to put it on
every page but if you want to track
website behavior on every page or
website then it needs to go on every
page of your website so if you're using
a you know platform like Drupal or
Joomla or even more popular platform
like WordPress adding the tracking code
site-wide is as easy as maybe adding a
Google Analytics plug-in to WordPress
for example and then just simply plug it
in the ID now there's an alternative to
adding the Google Analytics tracking
code to your site and that's Google tag
manager so Google tag manager is the way
I would recommend going so if you're not
familiar with Google tag manager I would
recommend watching the YouTube video we
have on Google tag manager you can just
go to youtube type in simply learn a
Google tag manager and this will give
you a nice overview of you know what
Google tag manager is and how it works
but basically this is the way I would go
and I would recommend that in addition
having Google Analytics you set up a
Google tag manager account and then that
way you can put the tracking code in
Google tag manager so if I go to Google
tag manager and I just go into an
account on tag manager I can just simply
put in the Google Analytics ID right
into tag manager and so if I have it in
tag manager then tag manager is going to
be the place that holds the code and
fires page view when somebody comes to
my website so that way I don't have to
add the tracking code to my website if I
do it in tag manager so that's the
recommended method for me is to add the
Google Analytics ID associated with tag
manager if you can associate it with tag
manager then that's the easier route to
go versus putting code on your website
ok so again take a look at the video we
have on YouTube for Google tag manager
that's the route I would go now once you
do get the tracking code on your website
whether that be through Google tag
manager or through a plug-in or you know
just simply adding the script to your
site to pages on your site then what's
going to happen is you're gonna start
collecting data so that's ideally the
way it works you need to add this code
your website now if you're not ready to
do that and you simply want to basically
understand how Google Analytics works
then I would recommend getting access to
Google Analytics demo account and so if
you just type in and search Google
Analytics demo account basically what
you're going to do you're gonna choose
the first listing there and you're gonna
go to demo account so if you have a
Google Analytics for Google login then
all you need to do is click on access
demo account and so what Google is gonna
do is put this demo account into your
account and so it's gonna look something
like this so if I click on demo account
here it's going to add to my Google
Analytics account so I'm gonna have then
access to the demo account from Google
in Google Analytics so I would recommend
going this route here if you're not
familiar you're not sure what you're
getting yourself into
so think of the demo account as kind of
a test drive your test driving Google
Analytics before you even add any code
to your website so again all you need is
a Google account and if you have a
Google account and you add the demo
account to your Google Analytics account
you're gonna be able to see how
analytics works okay and so that's what
I would also recommend so if you're not
ready to start adding code to your
website then what you can do is just
simply add the demo account and then
once you add the demo account you're
free to peruse around Google Analytics
to see the different types reports it
has to offer now when you do actually
set up a Google Analytics account and
you're gonna have some settings that
you're gonna want to pay attention to so
when you set up the account you have the
account name and then you have a
property so under each property you have
by default you're gonna have one view
and so here you can see this view here
so if we look at the account we set up
we set up a demo simply learn account
property is demo simply learn so that's
associated with the website we're going
to track and then again by default under
each property you're going to have
a view and so by default the name of the
view is going to be called all website
data and so in that view is where all
your Analytics data is going to be
stored so you could see my screen here
there's a lot of different settings you
have you have settings under the account
you have settings under the property and
you have settings under the view so
we're going to talk more about these
settings and future webinars for
advanced Google Analytics users but for
now know that there's a bunch of
settings that you have that you can play
around with when it comes to Google
Analytics anything from adding users to
your Google Analytics account your
Google Analytics property or view you
can actually set up goals you could set
up filters you can set up segments you
can link up Google Ads
you can you know set up remarketing
lists there's a lot you can do in terms
of the settings as it relates to Google
Analytics but so know those settings are
there they're located right down here
and this little sprocket icon that's the
admin icon so if you need to get to
these settings at any time you could
simply just click on the sprocket or the
admin icon and then you'll be prompted
to choose any one of these settings here
that you want to edit or alter so now
let's take a look at some Google
Analytics reports so once you've
actually set up your account you have a
number of different reports that you
have available to you in Google
Analytics so we're going to take a look
at you know customized reports we're
going to get real-time audience reports
acquisition behavior and conversion so
these are all the different reporting
buckets if you will that you have
available to you in Google Analytics so
if I'm an admin and I'm looking at the
Google demo account let's start out by
looking at real time so if I click on
the real time report and I just click on
overview so basically what this is going
to do is show me at this point in time
how many users I actually have active on
the website okay so that's why they call
it real-time reporting because it allows
you to see
the behavior of users who are currently
on your website and so this is the
overview report under real time and you
can see here I can see that 79 percent
of my users are coming from desktop 18
percent 20 percent are coming from
mobile and then approximately 3 percent
of coming from tablet here I can see how
they actually came to the website so
this is the referring source if they
came from say search or social I can see
the source there and I can see what
pages they're active on and then here I
could see what locations where they're
located and so if I want to see a
breakdown of everything in the overview
I can certainly do that if I go to
locations under real time I could see a
majority on my users are coming from the
United States ok where are they coming
from I'll just click on traffic sources
in here I could see the different
sources and mediums medium is the means
in which the traffic was driven so if
it's Google
it's either paid search or organic
search so I can see here it's organic
then I can actually see what contents
they're looking at on my website so I
can see currently have 3 active users on
the home page 2 active users on the
Google's women's white tee page so forth
and so on
now most importantly if you have a vent
tracking set up so if you taking a look
at our Google tag manager webinar you
know that you could set up a vent
tracking in Google Analytics to measure
engagement on your website whether that
be a form submission or somebody
clicking on the play button of a video
so if I click on events I'll be able to
see what events are firing so here I can
see we have a vent tracking setup and I
can see how many different events are
firing on my website in real time so
here I can see ecommerce somebody
clicking on the quick view click some a
couple of users clicking on add to cart
a couple of users clicking on the
promotion click and as these events are
fired you're going to be able to see
them highlighted so if something gets
fired it's going to get highlighted and
I could see
that these are the current events that I
have currently firing on the website and
that's what's currently fire now if I
want to look at the events that have
happened in the last 30 minutes I can
just click on this link here last 30
minutes and it's going to give me an
overview of the events that have
happened over the past 30 minutes okay
so that's event tracking and then more
importantly we can also look at what
conversions are happening in real time
just by clicking on conversions and so
now I can see I had one active user who
entered the checkout so that's gold
number four so in analytics you can have
up to 20 goals and so here I can see we
have goal number four has already had
one active user and so if I look at the
last 30 minutes I can see I still have
only one goal over the last 30 minutes
and that was somebody who entered the
checkout so that's real-time reporting
in summary it just gives you an idea of
what's currently happening on your
website and so for me ideally if I'm
launching a campaign or let's just say
you do a new website redesign and you
want to see how users performing and
behaving then real-time is a good option
for you so you can see how things are
happening in real time now let's jump
down to audience reporting so if I click
on audience if it's just right
underneath real time I'm gonna see a
number of different reports available to
me under audience and so let's click on
the audience overview report so audience
reporting basically allows us to get a
sense of who is coming to our website
when I say who is coming to our website
it doesn't necessarily a specific person
in fact Google doesn't allow personally
identifiable information in Google
Analytics personal identifiable
information such as a specific name
social security number credit card
information etc however we could still
paint a nice picture on who is coming to
our website
meaning what country city or state did
they come from what language what device
do they get to our website from how old
were they okay were they male or female
or other what interests do they have
what browser do they is so we can paint
a nice picture based on all this
information that Google Analytics is
providing us under audience so if I go
to audience overview here I can see I
have all these different options
available to me to get a basic
understanding of who is coming to our
website so for example I could see a
majority of the people coming to our
website speak English and are from the
United States okay in fact that
represents 61% of the users and so
Google Analytics does a great job of
giving me an overall percentage so if I
have a hundred percent of the users
I could see sixty-one percent of those
users represented english-speaking users
from the United States seven percent
represented english-speaking users from
Great Britain and so when it comes to
analytics we have users and users are
broken down into two categories there
either returning or they're new so when
you add the Google Analytics tracking
script to your website what's going to
happen is if a user or when a user goes
to your website they're going to get
cookie if it's the first time they've
been to your website what Google
Analytics is going to do is store a
cookie in the browser so when that same
user comes back another day in the same
browser analytics is going to recognize
that that cookie is in the browser and
so then analytics is going to categorize
that user as a returning user okay so
that's how analytics is able to
differentiate new versus returning so if
that user doesn't have a cookie in the
browser then analytics is going to
recognize that store the cookie and then
count that user as a new user and so
when you're looking at analytics you're
going to be able to see a breakdown of
new versus returning so here I can see
over 3/4 of my traffic over the past
week here I can see April 6 through
April 12 3 over 3/4 our new users to the
website here I could see about 23 24
sent our returning users okay so I can
get a good breakdown of what type of
users are coming am i driving any
traffic am i driving traffic that's
meant to my website before what language
are they speaking okay I can also paint
a bigger picture how old are they are
they what gender are they do they come
from mobile so let's take a look at some
of these different reports under
audience so if I skip down now to
demographics I can click on overview and
when that report loads I can see now
under demographics overview I can see
the breakout of age ranges and so here I
can see the majority of the traffic
coming to my site again over the past
week now if I want to change this date
range I could simply do that I can
change the date range just by clicking
on the date range and then maybe going
say the last 30 days and I can even
compare it to the previous period or the
previous year I'm gonna choose the last
30 days I'm gonna click apply now I'm
looking at data over the last 30 days
and again you can change the date range
to any range you want you can only go
back as far as when you actually created
the Google Analytics account
you can't go prior to that so here I'm
looking at the last 30 days and I can
see almost 47% of my users were in their
age range of 25 to 34 now when it comes
to gender
I can see 66% represent males so I can
get a breakout of gender and age as well
as interest and click on interest and
look at the overview there and see what
the interest is of the users are coming
to my site based on in market segments
or affinity I can also choose language
and location so if I want to know
exactly where my users are located when
they're coming to my website I can click
on location and here I can get a
breakout 43% of the users of the last 30
days were from the United States more
importantly I can align my audience
with goals we'll talk about goals here
in a minute but here I can see five an
e-commerce website I can see of those
43% point to 9% of those converted or
purchase something and that equates to
94 transactions so I can get a good
sense of not only how many users are
coming from a specific country but are
those users converting if I click on
mobile and mobile to me is one of those
reports I tend to spend a bit of time on
because I want to know what devices
users are coming to my website and so
for my website here or this is the
Google demo website
I can see mobile represents
approximately 27% of the traffic so
desktop still represents a majority of
the traffic so for you you want to keep
an eye on mobile because mobile is
definitely a majority of what people use
nowadays that's how people start their
day that's how they transact via mobile
whether that's purchasing something
communicating or searching it all starts
with mobile so you want to keep an eye
on mobile and more importantly you want
to keep an eye on behavior so Google
Analytics is telling me that yes I
approximately 27% of my traffic of the
last 30 days came from mobile how are
they interacting with my website so if I
look across this report I'm gonna be
able to see different metrics so if I'm
measuring specific metrics against my
dimension in this case the dimension is
what we're measuring and in this example
we're measuring mobile I can see that
the bounce rate is approximately 48
percent and bounce rate means that if a
user in this case from mobile landed on
a page they left the site without going
any further so they consider it a bounce
if they don't go to another page if they
leave the site from the page they landed
on and they don't go any further that's
considered a bounce
so bounce rate is the percentage of
people who come to the site and leave
the site without going
any further so in this case we have 48
percent bounce rate that's almost half
of our users should come from mobile
leave the website from the page they
landed on so is that good is that bad
well it's open to interpretation is
definitely subjective but you want to
keep the bounce rate as low as possible
you want to keep people on your site
especially if you have an e-commerce
website you want people who come to your
website to purchase and so here we could
see 48 percent mobile in desktop it's a
little bit lower at 41% now if I look a
little bit further at engagement I can
see how many pages on average do mobile
users look at so versus desktop it's a
little bit lower you can see 3.86
on desktop it's four point five now if I
look a little bit further in engagement
I want to be able to measure how long
somebody from mobile stays on the
website if they're bouncing a 48% but
they're also looking at three point
eight pages three point nine almost four
pages per session then that means in
this report analytics is telling me
they're spending about two minutes on
the site and interestingly enough I can
see that mobile over the last 30 days
had more transactions so 51 transactions
versus thirty four transactions from
desktop and interestingly enough the
commerce conversion rate is at point two
nine percent that's higher than desktop
at point zero seven it's lower than
tablet but it's higher than desktop and
mobile has the most transactions and
since they are the most transactions
they have the most revenue at 2380 so
yes the engagement isn't exactly as
great as it is as desktop but we can see
that people are still purchasing with
their mobile devices so it's something
to keep an eye on and mobile is
something I definitely look at in fact
since it's such an important report one
thing you can do in analytics is if you
actually like a report and you think
you're gonna look at that report
multiple times then you can simply
just go ahead and click Save at the top
here so if I click Save I'm going to
enter a name for this report I'm just
gonna call it mobile report and click OK
and then what's gonna happen is it's
gonna be located under save reports and
save reports is located under
customization customization is located
above real time okay so if I close that
up you can see audience real time
customization if I click on
customization if I click on save reports
I should be able to see my save report
here and I do so here I can see mobile
report if I click on it I can simply go
to the report I was looking at before I
saved it so save reports to me is a good
feature in analytics because it allows
you to quickly access a report that
you've saved in the past so let's take a
look at one more report under audience
now let's go to benchmarking so remember
when we were setting up our analytics
account we had the option to opt in to
benchmarking and I recommended you do so
and so if you did actually opt in to
benchmarking then you're going to be
able to see how your site compares to
others in the same industry so if I
click on benchmarking and then click on
channels what I'm actually able to do
now is compare my website with others in
the same industry so if I go back to say
jobs in education and I choose education
all education as my industry vertical I
should be able to see websites that are
in the same particular industry and how
I compared with those websites so I'm
choosing all countries I can narrow that
down if I wanted to I can just search
for the United States
I can choose a specific state and then I
can choose a particular site size so
here I'm choosing sites by daily
sessions so these are sites that have an
average of 5,000 to almost 10,000
sessions a day and so in this vertical
education in the United States sites
that have 5,000 to 9,000 900
99 sessions per day that means that
they're approximately 310 web properties
contributing to this report okay based
on this criteria
I chose now if my site is similar
meaning if I'm in the United States if
I'm in education and I'm receiving 5,000
to 9999 sessions per day then I'm able
to compare my site against 310 other
websites now Google's sharing this data
anonymously from the other websites and
they're doing the same with your website
to those particular websites
benchmarking reports okay so it's a
shared data anonymously in particular
industries and verticals and so now I'm
looking at a channel report so if I want
to see how I compared to others in my
industry then I can go ahead and see my
channel for example am i driving as much
traffic as others in my industry and you
can see I'm not in fact I'm 76 77
percent worse in terms of the amount of
traffic being driven from organic search
so anything in red is going to show as a
negative result and negative comparison
whereas something in green is a positive
comparison so if I look at engagement I
can see that I might not be driving as
much traffic but I can see that the
pages per session are better than the
site average or the industry average I
can see if I go over again looking just
at organic search I can see the bounce
rate is better than the industry average
so the channel report under benchmarking
allows you to measure how you compare to
others in your industry and you could do
so by looking at location and devices so
if you opted in to benchmarking when you
set up your account then you'll be able
to compare your website against others
in your industry in your country region
and based on the size of your website in
terms of how many visitors or sessions
you're getting per day so let's go from
audience to acquisition
so if audience is who is coming to your
website acquisition
allows us to see how the traffic was
driven to your website so how did these
users get to our website and so under
acquisition if we click on overview
we'll be able to see an overview of how
users whether they're returning or new
came to our website and so what
analytics does by default is they have a
number of default channels and when we
say channels we mean analytics is
grouping different channels based on how
users got to your website meaning how
did users get to our website did they
come via organic search meaning did they
type something into Google and find you
in the organic listing analytics also
groups users based on whether they came
to your site directly meaning did they
type in the URL directly into the
browser or did they bookmark your
website and come back via the bookmark
so they're grouping users under direct
they also group users under referral
meaning did they come from another
website they group users by social did
they come from a social media platform
like Twitter or Facebook if you're
running paid search meaning if you're
running paid search on say Google then
do they come from paid search ads now if
you're running display ads on say
Google's Network Google's Display
Network that's a default channel so
analytics will group users there so if
they don't recognize a channel then
they're going to group it as other so by
default Google Analytics groups users
and how they came to your website via
these default channels and so I can see
how many users came to the site from
each Channel now if I want to drill down
on this report I can click on all
traffic and then if I click on all
traffic I can go to channels I can look
specifically at the channels report it
so now I can see organic search again
over the last thirty days is the number
one Channel driving traffic and they
represent approximately again you can
see this number here in parentheses next
to the raw number of users I can see
that number is about 56 percent so 56
percent of my
traffic over the last 30 days came from
organic search and so those are the
number users again as a metric you're
also going to have sessions and you'll
see sessions a lot as a metric so users
are broken down between new and
returning so every time a new or
returning user comes to the website
basically what they're doing is
initiating a session so you can have a
user who can come back multiple times
every time they come back to the website
it's a session so session is simply the
start of somebody coming to your website
and the session ends when they leave the
website and so just like we looked at
with the audience reports when it came
to mobile we can also look at engagement
by channel so just like mobile we looked
at bounce rate pages per session average
session duration we can do the same
thing here with our channel report more
importantly in addition to behavior we
can see conversions and since we're
running an e-commerce platform we could
see what the conversion rate is by
channel so organic search did drive the
most traffic and they did have the most
transactions over the last 30 days and
the conversion rate in this case is
point one seven okay so how Google
determines the conversion rate they
basically take the number of
transactions and divide that by sessions
so that means that over the last 30 days
organic search drove thirty eight
thousand 123 sessions and of those
thirty eight thousand 123 64 actually
turned into a transaction which equates
to point one seven which also equates to
three thousand and revenue so I'm able
to determine not only how users are
getting to my website by looking at the
channel report I can actually see if
they're engaging and if they are
converting and notice when you look at a
report in analytics you can look at it
by Channel you'll also get a summary so
here I can see a summary or a total
based on my date range so I
see over the last 30 days I've had
fifty-four thousand users forty nine
thousand of them were new okay that
meant that Eva's for fifty four thousand
users I had seventy thousand sessions I
can see my average bounce rate was 43
percent the pages per session were just
over four and the average session
duration how long did somebody stay on
my website on average about two minutes
and 55 seconds
the average conversion rate was 0.14 and
at a total 97 transactions totaling
$5,500 and that's all over the last 30
days so any report you look at in
analytics is going to have a summary and
note that any report you look at in
analytics is going to allow you to save
it so if it's a report you think you're
gonna go back and look at at a future
date then you simply just have to click
on the Save button
conversely if you don't want to save it
you can simply just export it so you can
export it as a PDF if I click on PDF
it's going to allow me to export that as
a PDF now you have other options
available to you as well you can do a
Google sheet you can export it as an
excel or you can export it as a comment
delimited file so here you can see I can
save it as a PDF if I want to and if I
click OK it's going to save to my
desktop or a location of my choosing and
then I can go back and look at it in
that format at a later time so that's
the export feature available to you and
analytics again if you you could save it
as well or you can export it okay some
other reports under acquisition if
you're running Google Ads note that you
can connect Google Ad to analytics and
this is key because now I can see how
many people are coming from Google Ads
to my website and are they converting
now this is important because with
Google Ads I'm actually paying for the
click so you can see here I'm running a
report based on campaign data so I could
see what campaigns are driving traffic
how much of pain per click and you can
see on average
paying 34 cents per click and then more
importantly I want to be able to see if
they're converting so you can see I've
spent eight hundred and ten dollars over
the last 30 days and received eight
hundred and fifty eight dollars in
revenue so you want to make sure that
you link up your Google Ads account to
your Google Analytics account for this
very reason you want to be able to see
how your Google ads campaigns perform
once the users get to your website and
so I want to see if they're engaging and
I want to see if they're converting so
there are all sorts of reports under
Google Ads
so you can look at it by keywords by
search queries by hour of the day if
you're running display campaigns you can
look at display targeting so there's all
sorts of reports under Google Ads you
just have to link it up and you link it
up under the admin now there are other
reports that you can look at so if I go
to campaigns I can look at all campaigns
so if you're running all sorts of
different types of campaigns whether
that be on Facebook whether it be email
whether that be you know other types of
advertising let's just say Twitter or
Instagram you're going to be able to see
those campaigns here and that's under
all campaigns and again you'll be able
to see the campaign name and you'll be
able to see metrics associated with
those campaigns and more importantly
you'll be able to see your ecommerce if
you run in e-commerce platform or if you
have goals set up so you'll be able to
look at how your campaigns are not one
not only driving traffic but - are they
converting let's go from acquisition
reporting to behavior so behavior
reports are going to actually show you
how users behaved once they got to your
website once they landed on a page on
your website how did they behave so when
we looked at audience we got a sense of
who is coming with acquisition we get a
sense of how the traffic got to our
website do they come from organic direct
social etc the behavior reports allow us
to actually measure
how that traffic behave once they landed
on a page on our website and so if I go
to overview under behavior now I'm
looking at this graph here it's shown me
how many pages have had and a page U is
simply once a page is viewed it's
counted as a page view so if a user
comes to my site they're initiating a
session and if they look at a page then
that page is going to have a page view
okay so a user can look at a page
multiple times in a session and every
time they look at that page it's going
to count as a page view so here I can
see in this graph how many kgs I've had
again over the last thirty days and if I
look further at my overview report I can
see the specific pages and how many
pages they've had and I can also look at
some other metrics
okay the average bounce rate the average
time on page I can look at the exit rate
which means how many people actually
exited or the percentage of people who
exited from that page so I can dig
deeper into my behavior reporting so if
I click on site content and I click on
all pages then I'm going to look at a
report by page this is my dimension this
is what I'm measuring my page and now I
can see how many page views each page
had over the last 30 days now know you
also have something called unique
pageviews so unique pageviews is
equivalent to one per session in other
words if the user came to my site and
looked at the home page then the home
page is going to have one unique page
view in one page view now if the user in
that same session looks at other pages
then every page that user looks at it's
gonna have one unique page you however
if the user goes back to a to the same
page in the same session then it's still
gonna be one unique page view but in
this case the home page if they look at
the home page a second time then the
home page is gonna have two pageviews if
they look at the home page five times in
one session then the home page is gonna
have five total pageviews in one unique
page view okay so that's why unique
pages is equivalent to one
session where page ease is accumulation
of how many times the page was viewed in
the same session so in other words
you're always going to have more page
views than unique pages okay so this
gives me a sense of how my page is
performed so again I can look at total
page views and then engagement so
ideally what you want to do with a
report like this is if a user is not
engaging on the page then that should
tell you something about the page itself
if they're not engaging of the bounce
rates high if the time on page is low if
the exit percentage of exit rate is high
then you probably want to do something
with that page now these are all pages
but if I jump down to landing pages my
landing page report is showing me how
many people actually landed on that page
and so here I can see under my landing
page report I can see the home page had
thirty six thousand seventeen sessions
in the last thirty days that's how many
people landed on the home page so here I
can see seventy-one percent were new
sessions meaning that I had a lot of new
users who landed on the home page in
fact twenty-five thousand or fifty two
percent of the people who landed on the
home page for new I could see the bounce
rates about forty two percent but of
those who didn't bounce they went on to
look at about 4.5 pages per session and
spent about three minutes on the site
and the one thing I liked about the
landing page report is I can also see
whether that particular page in this
case the home page did it help
contribute to a goal or conversion and
in this case I can see of those thirty
six thousand sessions I had twenty two
transactions totaling twelve hundred in
revenue and that's an e-commerce
conversion rate of point zero six
percent so the home page over the last
30 days contributed to point zero six
percent of the revenue so this gives you
an idea of when somebody lands on your
website and they land on a page is that
page helping to move
that person along meaning are they not
bouncing and is that page helping to
move people towards converting and so
that's what the landing page and a fact
allows us to measure is the engagement
and in this case we're measuring
transactions
okay so analytics also gives us some
other reports under behavior including
site speed so site speed to me is an
important report to look at just like
the mobile report to me site speed is
important because what Google Analytics
does is they take a sampling of pages
and in this case you can see over the
last 30 days they sample 2835 pageviews
and of that sample they came back and
said the average page load time is about
four seconds now ideally you want to
keep it as quick as possible
I would say even under three seconds
okay now there are other factors
involved with page load time the browser
you're using the country that you are
actually browsing that page from Minot
how to have the best infrastructure you
name may not even be on the best
internet network meaning you're on a
cell network or the Wi-Fi is not that
grey or you can be on a page that just
has a lot of images or a lot of code
that may slow it down so there are other
factors involved and so what Google
Analytics does show you what those
factors are so here I can see by browser
what the average load time is if I want
to look at country I can see what
country is contributing to the low time
now the great thing about the site speed
report is if I go to speed suggestions
okay what speed suggestions is going to
do is it's going to show me the page
load time by page and then it's actually
going to provide a link where I can
actually click on to get suggestions on
increasing the page load time so for
example I can look at this particular
page here this Google redesign shop by
brand slash YouTube page line number
five if I look at line number five I can
see the average load time of this page
is 8 seconds almost 9 seconds ok that's
an eternity to some piece
now notice this link next to it so
Google's recommending seven total
suggestions so if I click on seven total
what it's actually going to do it's
going to open up a new window and it's
going to open up another Google report
called PageSpeed insights and PageSpeed
insights is going to give me some
information about what I can do to
create correct correct the page load of
that particular page so look at the site
speed report it's important because
there is a correlation between site
speed or page load time and user
behavior of that page and there's also
correlation between page load time and a
page ranking organically on search so
page load time is very important it's so
important that I'm even gonna save it so
I'm gonna click Save and click on speed
site speed suggestions as my name and
click OK and now that report is going to
be saved under customization under save
reports let's jump from behavior to
conversions now conversion reporting is
arguably the most important section in
in Google Analytics because what the
conversions reporting allows us to do is
see how people are converting or if
they're not converting on our website
and so in Google Analytics we have the
opportunity to set up goals now you have
the opportunity to set up 20 goals in
your Google Analytics view and so to set
up a goal ok so you're gonna click on
admin and under the view you're gonna
see goals and so if you don't even have
goals the first step is to create goals
and so you have four different gold
types and analytics so you have pages
per session so how many pages per
session is so if your goal is set to say
3 or 2 if somebody actually looked at 2
or 3 pages per session it's going to
count as a goal okay so if I look here I
could see I have pages per session set
at 10 so that means that if a user came
to the site looked at more than 10 pages
per session then it's going to count as
a goal another
type is destination so destination means
that if somebody actually went to a
specific page then it's going to count
as a goal and in this case I can see
here that the goal is set to this
particular page here and so when
somebody actually lands on that page
it's gonna count as a goal now there are
two other goal types we can look at one
is duration so just like pages per
session in our previous example if
somebody looked at ten pages per session
it's going to count as a goal what
duration is based on time so in this
particular case if you set up a duration
goal and the duration is set to say one
minute and thirty seconds then that
means if the user comes to my website
and they spent at least one minute and
30 seconds then it's going to count as a
goal okay and then the fourth type of
goal and Google Analytics is an
event-based goal so when you set up
event tracking you could turn that event
into a goal so if somebody clicks on say
the submit button of a form you can turn
that event into a goal so here you can
see the category equals contact form so
you can always verify if a goal works
just by clicking on verify this goal and
in this case this event is turned into a
goal so any time somebody fires this
event it's gonna count as a goal so you
have four different goal types in Google
Analytics you have pages per session
destination event and duration and so
once you've set up a goal then you can
measure goals under conversions so now
if I look at goals overview I can be
able to see how many total goal
completions I've had so if I want to
look at it by goal I can just choose the
goal option here so if I want to look at
for example goal two engaged users this
was the pages per session I can see that
I had a conversion rate at 10%
meaning that I had 7,000 of all the
users who came to the website 7,000 goal
completions meaning 7106 users
looked at ten pages or more on my
website and so that's how you want to be
able to measure whether users where
they're ever they're coming from whoever
they are whatever pages they look at you
want to be able to look at the
conversion reports to see if they're
actually converting based on the goals
you've set up whether that's pages per
session duration destination or event
goal conversion tracking reports can
help you measure who is actually
converting and the great thing about
Google Analytics here is that I can
actually see by segments so the default
segment in a segment is just looking at
a specific user set so the fault segment
is always all users however I can choose
a different segment so if I want to
choose instead of all users if I don't
choose mobile traffic
I can select mobile traffic hit apply
so I'm actually now looking at a subset
of data I'm looking at mobile traffic so
if all the mobile users have come to my
site I can see 1400 engaged or looked at
10 pages or more okay and that's a 7
percent conversion rate so the great
thing about Google Analytics is you have
the opportunity to set up for different
goal types okay based on those goal
types you can go to goals overview and
look at the conversion rate of each goal
but you can also change the segments of
that particular goal to see who exactly
converted ok another report I like under
conversions is the multi-channel funnel
report so if I click on multi-channel
funnel basically what this allows me to
do is see how different channels work
together to convert so remember the
channel reporting we looked at under
acquisition here I can see now how
different channels work together to
drive the conversion so if I look at
three channels direct organic and
referral I can see all three together
drive two percent of the conversions if
I look at direct and referral twelve and
a half percent if I look at direct and
organic twelve point two four percent so
I can see how different channels
together and so if I look at top
conversion paths as an example I can
actually see what channels how channels
work together to drive the conversion so
in this example I can see over the last
30 days
that my top channel grouping was direct
x - meaning that somebody came to the
website directly meaning they typed in
the URL in the browser or they
bookmarked it and came to the site okay
they came the first time but didn't
convert but then they came back a second
time via direct and then converted so
that combination is my top conversion
combination over the last 30 days my
second best conversion grouping is
organic search and direct meaning that a
user came to the website via organic
search first did not convert and then
came back via direct the second time and
converted so basically what analytics
does is give credit to the last referral
meaning if you came to the website via
referral a referring website and
converted then the referring website's
gonna get the credit for the conversion
but analytics does a good job of showing
you how different channels work together
so a channel may drive a lot of traffic
like organic search but that traffic may
not convert the first time around for
number different reasons whether it
could be brand recognition price
shopping reading content whatever the
case analytics is able to measure if
that channel actually did contribute at
a later point and in this case we could
see organic search drove traffic that
didn't convert but that traffic came
back a second time the interact and did
convert so that's our second and best
channel grouping and so the
multi-channel finally report top
conversion passed to me is a good report
to look at so you can actually see not
only a channels work together but you
can see sources and mediums and
campaigns and how all that all those
different campaigns from different
sources work together to convert so
that's just a good report to look at
there are so many different report
ports available and analytics there's so
many that we haven't even gotten to yet
so my advice if you look at the demo
report you can get a feel for each of
these reports under each section whether
it be audience acquisition behavior or
conversions take a look at these reports
see what makes sense to you see what you
can use to improve your website
performance now if you have any comments
or questions about any of the reports we
covered feel free to comment underneath
this video we're definitely gonna have
more webinars in the future about
specific analytics settings that we
didn't get to today and other types of
analytics reports and features that we
didn't get to today so I want to thank
you for attending today's webinar
certainly if you have more information
please visit simply learn comm thanks
and I'll see you future webinars
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here